programas STEAM de verano,
como también becas universitarias.
Necesitan entender
que cuando 200 jóvenes de Brownsville visitaron Harvard,
entendieron
que una universidad a su elección era una posibilidad real.
Y que los obstáculos que se les habían impuesto
por ser una comunidad en desventaja
fueron reemplazados por propósito y esperanza.
La revolución en la educación está ocurriendo en nuestras escuelas,
con adultos que dan amor,
estructura,
soporte
y conocimiento.
Estas son las cosas que inspiran a los niños.
Pero no es una tarea fácil.
Y hay altas demandas
dentro un sistema educativo que no es perfecto.
Pero tengo un grupo dinámico de educadores
que colaboran en equipo para formar el mejor plan de estudios.
Toman tiempo aparte de la escuela,
y vienen los fin de semana
e incluso usan su propio dinero para dar recursos
cuando no los tenemos.
Y como directora,
debo inspeccionar lo que espero.
Me presento en las clases
y hago observaciones para generar una retroalimentación,
porque quiero que mis profesores sean tan exitosos
como el nombre Academia Mott Hall Bridges.
Y los atiendo todos los días,
tienen mi número de teléfono,
incluso mis escolares y los graduados...
por lo cual recibo llamadas y mensajes de texto
a las 3 de la mañana.
(Risas)
Pero estamos todos conectados para el éxito,
y los líderes buenos hacen esto.
El futuro del mañana se sienta en nuestras aulas.
Y son nuestra responsabilidad.
Eso significa que todos aquí,
y los que miran por la pantalla.
debemos creer en su brillantez,
y recordarles al educarlos
que hay de hecho poder en la educación.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)